[Music]
and welcome back investigators in Moscow
Idaho are trying to clarify what they
know so far about the brutal murders of
four University of Idaho students police
released the statement saying there was
conflicting information released the
prosecutor's office said that the
suspect specifically targeted the
off-campus home of the students and that
one of one or more of the people who
lived there were undoubtedly targeted
but police say that was a
miscommunication and they do not know if
there was a specific Target for students
three women and one man were found
stabbed to death on November 13th the
coroner believes they were likely all
asleep when the attack started but some
of the victims did have defensive wounds
two surviving roommates called 9-1-1
from a cell phone the morning after the
attack so far no suspect has been
identified and the murder weapon hasn't
been found yet the University of Idaho
held a vigil Wednesday night remember
what's being called the Idaho four news
Nation correspondent Brian enten was
there and I actually she spoke with me
on Long crimes sidebar podcast
they initially said that the public was
not at risk and then of course got
pushed on that because they didn't have
any information about who the killer was
or what happened or a motive and then
had to backtrack on that also and say
well we can't really say that um so I
think they're trying to walk this line
but I mean you know how it is like this
is a small town people are literally
freaking out here like I mean I can't
like tell you that enough like people
don't go out at night they think the
Killer is among them here
um you know people have put double locks
on their doors I went to the vigil last
night they have um you know uh metal
detectors to get in and police with
binoculars up in the balconies so I
think they're walking this fine line of
trying to keep the community somewhat
calm
um but at the same time also being open
that like they don't really know what
happened
during Wednesday night's vigil family
members of the victims spoke about their
loved ones and even had a reminder for
everyone else
spent so much time with him and I want
to remind you
that that's the most important message
that we have for you and your families
is to make sure that you spend as much
time as possible with those people
because time is precious and it's
something you can't get back
these girls were absolutely beautiful
they've been friends
since sixth grade it's a shame
and it hurts but the beauty of the two
always being together something that
will will it Comforts us it lets us know
that they were with their their best
friends in the whole world
Terry look we're still in the early
phases of this case but you know I have
to ask do you think the authorities have
already botched this investigation you
know I wouldn't say botched Jesse but it
has been compromised to a certain extent
in my opinion look it was November 13th
that was 18 days ago and every day is a
passing day and it could become a cold
case and you know they actually have
done
thousands of tips they've actually had
150 interviews so it's not as though
they're not doing anything and they are
working State local and federal
authorities are all helping so they're
doing something but their biggest issue
right now is the fact that they have
miscommunicated and the fact that
they're withholding information they
haven't said what was going on they need
to make sure that what they're doing is
communicated to the public now I
understand they don't want to
communicate all of their leads but at
the same time we need to know what's
going on here Brian the back and the
fourth the back and the fourth do you
think that this was a targeted killing
or not so Jesse we only have so much
information but from what we do have I'm
leaning towards this being targeted now
could it be targeted for the individuals
or targeted for the location I don't
know but when I hear multiple stabbing
some people in the home survive some
people do not not gunshots but multiple
stabbings that seems personal to me like
someone either knew these people or
thought they knew these people it seems
targeted to me but of course we need
more information before we can make the
determination and look I think we have
to be clear that everyone has the best
intentions everyone wants to solve this
case and I think at the end of the day
we're going to have to be patient take
it day by day and we are going to
continue to follow this case here on
Long crime daily because it's important
and we want a resolution as quickly as
possible and welcome back everybody
Thursday Mark day four in the trial of a
former border patrol agent accused of
going on a killing spree in Texas
investigators believe one David Ortiz is
accused or responsible for shooting Four
Women and leaving their bodies near I-35
and Laredo police say he preyed on women
doing sex work as some sort of vigilante
killer a fifth alleged victim managed to
escape at a gas station and she told a
state trooper that Ortiz tried to kidnap
her she testified that she knew all four
of the women who were killed she
mentioned the killings to Ortiz who she
said got very nervous at the time of his
arrest in 2018 Ortiz had worked for U.S
Customs and Border Protection for nine
years during a 10-hour invest
interrogation officers say Ortiz
confessed to the killings but the
defense says that alleged confession was
false Brian what are your thoughts on
the prosecution playing a 10-hour
interrogation video for the jury who are
you trying to bore to death I mean I get
it it's 10 hours long a lot of this case
is going to come down to whether or not
this was a true or false confession but
I think you can accomplish that goal by
showing the most relevant portions of
the the confession presented to the jury
explain to them how long it is and do
them a favor tell them you're only
giving them certain sections rather than
them getting frustrated at you probably
sit there for such a long presentation I
just hope that they were awake through
all of it because that's a problem Terry
we heard testimony from an alleged
victim someone who apparently survived
an attack testified about her encounter
with Ortiz how do think her testimony is
going to impact the jury impact this
case oh it's going to be a huge impact
on this case
surviving
Vic you better believe that that jury is
listening to every word that she is
saying they are listening to what he did
to her he picked her up he threw her in
the van he put a gun to her head and she
got out of that car and she was able to
escape she got help from a state trooper
and I think the jury is thinking this
must have happened exactly the same way
with the other women and so she was able
to tell the story for everyone a key
strategic move on the part of the
prosecution they put her up the first
day and had that impact I think that
they were looking for even though she
did admit that she did prostitution and
drugs I don't think the jury is going to
hold that against her well as we talk
about this unbelievable testimony and as
the Juan David Ortiz trial was underway
on Thursday there was other shocking
news and Associate associate district
attorney quit that's right according to
local television stations in Texas in
Texas Joshua Davila posted on Facebook
quote I have officially left the Webb
County District Attorney's office that
is the most unprofessional and toxic
workplace I have ever had to deal with I
do not recommend it Davila was actually
in the courtroom for the first three
days of the trial even questioning
Witnesses on the stand the District
Attorney's Office wouldn't comment other
than to say that his resignation
wouldn't impact the trial
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]